yeah so how did you start to come to
view stories in this symbolic fashion so
you're saying you're 22
or you just graduated from college and
your teacher was telling you
you don't belong here yeah you're a
traditionalist
the questions you're asking are are not
the ones that
you'll find the answer to not in college
yeah well
so what what basically happened is i
i tried to make contemporary art for a
little while i had a studio with some
friends and you know i was kind of
working towards something and then just
for freelance just for some money well
i hope like a real artist like go into a
gallery and do do do
do the real artist thing you know i made
these giant you know kind of
really ego ego driven giant giant uh
works of art you know that my whole life
is just one big giant ego-driven work of
art
so anyway so that's what i had and then
i i
uh i got married and marriage really
kind of
slammed me against myself right like i
saw all my own flaws
flowers insecurities and passions and
and uh
unreasonableness and all that just kind
of came flying back can you explain how
that happens
because i've recently got married and so
i want to know i wonder what's the story
from it depends on people
some people some people get married and
then it's wonderful for a little while
and then it then then the mirror starts
to show
um for me it was the opposite like we
got married like a week after we got
married all of a sudden
it was like could you see both of us
could just see
so our first year marriage was hell like
it was it was almost the opposite of
most people oh yeah
it was absolute hell like we once we got
through the first year of marriage
we were like huh you never get worse
than that so
it's pretty good let's keep going and so
so i mean it depends on people that's
how it was for us
did you live together beforehand no no
um and so so it was like that just
seeing this mirror and so it led me to a
lot of questioning and
and uh and also just kind of spiritual
crisis in general i was also becoming
very disillusioned with
the world the kind of evangelical world
that i was in in college i'd read a lot
of
of authors a lot of philosophers and
i just felt like the church where i was
going just wasn't
answering the questions what kind of
church was it this is kind of a
baptist baptist evangelical baptist
church
kind of american style church there uh
not liturgical you know just very kind
of looks like a business meeting can you
explain what you mean when you say
liturgical do you mean to say
it studies the bible no liturgical means
that it's
that it has a service which is which is
a pattern right
it's based on it's not just a
so like let's say a evangelical church
today
they'll get together they'll sing songs
and uh they'll have a sermon
but they'll say things like we could do
it we could do whatever like we you know
there's no
it doesn't matter which there's no
structure or you mean no structure for
your life or no structure for them
for the meetings right instruction for
the church and so liturgical means that
there's an order of service
and so there's we we do things in a
certain order like the jehovah's
witnesses i don't know if you're
familiar with them
yeah well they're not surgical
they're more like more like the
evangelical baptist
so liturgical is like anglican catholics
orthodox
they're liturgical so they sing they
they they have a
the building the the the architecture of
the building
is meaningful the order of the service
is meaningful the way the
the priest is dressed is meaningful
everything is
is done in a manner which is meaningful
and which is uh
which which manifests what you're trying
to do right
so it's not just it's not just arbitrary
so so anyway so i wasn't so i was going
to a kind of evangelical church
and um i felt like it was just lacking
in
in profundity lacking and meeting and
and also
you know i was reading philosophers and
then i started reading
authors from other traditions buddhist
authors sufi authors
and i discovered mystical the mystical
way you could say
the mystical thinking and uh
transformational thinking you could call
it
and uh i was really impressed by by it
and then i thought whoa i would say why
is it that christians don't have that
like why is it the christians don't have
the mystical mystical transformations
and mystical
vision of how the world works and and
all of that and and
it was only because it did it just i
didn't know about it
and then i that's when i discovered the
early church fathers
and traditional christianity and then
iconography